a coming-of-age movie with the superhero
twist Sky High left a lasting impression
on both kids and former kids so why has
a sequel never seen the light of day
debuting in theaters the same year as
Batman Begins and one year after
Spider-Man 2 Sky High was poised to
become as big a blockbuster as either of
those other films Disney still years
away from purchasing comic book
Juggernaut Marvel may even have been
banking on it but when it arrived it
wasn't the Smash Hit Studio execs were
hoping for
so unfair if life were to suddenly get
there I doubt it would happen in high
school while the film did more than
double its modest budget it didn't crack
100 million dollars worldwide that left
Hollywood cool on the idea of a sequel
and since then the cast and crew have
gone on to have bigger more prosperous
careers Kurt Russell has made a
Resurgence largely thanks to his role in
Quentin Tarantino's the hateful eight
while Mary Elizabeth Winstead became a
star thanks to 2010's Scott Pilgrim Vs
the World on television Daniel Panabaker
became a different superhero on the CW's
The Flash while Nicholas Braun garnered
a pair of Emmy nominations thanks to his
role in the HBO drama succession
getting the gang back together may not
be such an easy feat but there have been
plenty of rumors over the years implying
that such an event could still happen
just because Sky High wasn't a huge box
office success doesn't mean that it has
no Die Hard fans on the contrary it's
managed to develop a fan base containing
both comic book fans and Disney lovers
and those involved with the film
continue to be asked about the
possibility of more stories set in its
Universe to this very Day in 2020 writer
Mark McCorkle who was also the
co-creator of Kim Possible and has since
written The Penguins of Madagascar and
Big Hero 6 the series spoke about a
potential follow-up to the 2005 film he
told inverse over the years we always
thought maybe a sequel could happen one
of these days there was always a belief
that this was a rich enough world to
keep going with new ideas I guess if the
film still has that same affection of
people watching it and streaming It on
Disney plus who knows maybe if the
people speak their wishes will be
answered McCorkle isn't the only one
hoping for Sky High too Daniel Panabaker
who portrayed the plant-loving pacifist
Layla told the international business
times in 2018 I would do anything to
make another one Mary Elizabeth Winstead
who played the Techno baby themed super
villain royal pain doesn't seem to think
her story is over either when asked
about the character's future on the
ladies night podcast she said I think
she's still operating as a super villain
for sure I don't think there was any
moral reassessment for her actions
Winstead even joked that instead of
reverting everyone back into babies
royal pain would spend the sequel
turning innocent students into senior
citizens patience
waited this long when the time is right
we'll have our revenge with so many
years having passed since Sky High was
in theaters it's fair to ask who would
actually return if a sequel was
Greenland while not everyone has
directly addressed their possible return
there are a few who have and thankfully
Michael angarano is one of them angorano
who played lead character Will
Stronghold told ultimate Disney not long
after the first film's release I would
be up for a sequel for sure especially
if everyone from this film was also
involved but would everyone else be
involved Daniel Panabaker seems to think
so based on comments she made in 2018.
she elaborated I just saw Nick Braun and
Michael angarano at a party in LA and I
love those boys so much I would see Mary
Elizabeth Winstead when we were both
working in Vancouver I think it would be
great and I think we would all jump at
the opportunity
the students of Sky High aren't the only
ones interested in continuing The Story
actor Kevin hepernen who played bus
driver Ron Wilson was quick to affirm
that he would absolutely return for a
sequel at a press junket for another
film he gushed I would love to I mean
that cast the cast is amazing the array
of people in that cast is phenomenal
been no concrete talk of a Sky High
sequel since the first movie was
released that doesn't mean that those
involved haven't had ideas regarding
where the story should go in 2019
director Mike Mitchell opened up about
his concept for Sky High too including a
proposed title Mitchell told io9 I am
hugely proud of it and they should make
it a franchise we have a whole sequel
that's called save you or save
University from the sounds of it the
sequel would have sent the young Heroes
off to college where they surely would
have meant even more young men and women
training to become the world's next
Defenders of humanity Mitchell isn't the
only one with fun ideas of where the
story could go more recently Daniel
Panabaker shared her thoughts on a
different story one that takes into
account the long amount of time that has
passed since the first movie She
elaborated I'd like to think that maybe
their teachers at Sky High because it's
been long enough that they could go back
and teach they could be the young cool
hip teachers and then they're teaching
the next class of superheroes
with efforts to get a cinematic sequel
to Sky High having stalled for years
it's worth asking if the creators should
be looking at other ways to bring a
follow-up to life while they could
continue the story in comic form the way
shows like Smallville and Firefly have
they could also opt for television that
was apparently once on the drawing board
as director Mike Mitchell revealed
during an interview with Gizmodo in
2019. according to the filmmaker the
studio originally had bigger plans than
just movies as he explained except for
Kurt Russell and Kelly Preston every
actor signed a contract to make it into
a TV show
it's nice to know that whatever happens
to me
you'll still be around to save the world
looking forward to it Disney presumably
wanted Sky High to become a TV hit on
their very own Disney Channel led by the
young cast rather than pricier big
screen Stars however the movie's
unremarkable performance at the box
office left it overshadowed by other
family films like March of the Penguins
and Charlie and the Chocolate Factory
could a TV sequel still materialize
Mitchell isn't sure but he's totally on
board and just waiting for Disney to
give the word he joked dude I'm ready to
go it's up to you in the media just
write that it's happening
it's been a long time since 2005. in the
Disney Channel along with pretty much
every other cable network is far from
the Juggernaut it once was that hasn't
stopped the massive company from
producing plenty of content for their
streaming service Disney plus and the
service might just be the perfect home
for a Sky High sequel writer Mark
McCorkle certainly thinks so he told
inverse in 2020 to me it's a very
natural fit for Disney plus and over the
years we always thought maybe a sequel
could happen one of these days
that interview immediately sparked wild
speculation that Disney was developing a
Sky High sequel project for the
streaming service
nothing was ever confirmed and the
rumors are still nothing more than
rumors it's not hard to imagine Sky High
becoming a Disney plus feature film
series or episodic Adventure it could
all happen on a relatively modest budget
and would surely attract plenty of long
time fans
it may not have attracted lines of
people around the block but Sky High has
become beloved by Disney fans for its
bright cheery tone and colorful
family-friendly action though many years
have passed since the movie was released
enthusiasm for it and a possible sequel
has never waned on websites like Reddit
and Twitter fans of the original film
Express their love and call for a sequel
nearly two decades later in 2020 a
petition to get a sequel up and running
cropped up complete with an idea on what
it could be about the fan proposed 2020
marks the 15-year anniversary of the
release of this Smash Hit And we propose
that the original cast and creators of
Sky High reunite for a sequel depicting
a high school reunion featuring the
characters we have all adored for well
over a decade even though the petition
didn't Garner as much support as other
fan-driven attempts to get movies made
have its mere existence demonstrates
just how passionate Sky High fans are
when life gives you lemons
make apple juice
can't make lemons I don't know what it
is
Sky High may have been a little too far
ahead of its time striking when colorful
superheroes were on their way out and
darker grittier superheroes were on
their way in it missed the era of the
Cinematic Universe by a few years too
meaning that some may think that
audiences have no interest in a sky-high
sequel nowadays but there's more reason
to believe that the world needs a Sky
High sequel now more than ever in the
last decade superhero movies from Marvel
and DC have gotten almost too popular
for their own good reaching a critical
mass that has seen some audiences
souring on their latest offerings Marvel
has engulfed in a complicated Multiverse
story and their latest entries have been
met with lackluster reception meanwhile
things got so bad for DC that they
decided to reboot their Cinematic
Universe entirely both have become so
overwrought bats at times it feels like
all the fun has been sucked out of them
Sky High sequel could be just the
antidote as Mike McCorkle said Mike
Mitchell had a vision of bright colors
and it being friendly and upbeat Sky
High proved that you can be bright and
colorful and still resonate with real
human emotions a throwback to a simpler
era a Sky High sequel could be the
hopeful optimistic family-friendly
superhero adventure that the movies had
been missing
foreign